18 ans la liberté comme un an
non mais aussi pascal sevran et allan
voilà pascal sevran et alan je vois je
vois pascal que vous portez votre légion
d'honneur
oui je te réponds vient chez toi ça
faisait plus chez bien on peut voir de
réussir de guerre bon on peut voir deux
de blessures de guerre
le mérite agricole non pourquoi pas je
viens alors résumé des épisodes
précédents pascal a organisé sur france
2 un concours de chanteurs et de
chanteuses intitulé entrée d'artistes
5000 candidats 400 audition 40
sélectionné quatorze finalistes et un
vainqueur allan
tous des garçons
pour ne pas vivre en paix en france des
enfants qui sont sains
les inquiets pour les quatre 1999 fameux
boucherie la sélection écoute bien le
début
les filles aiment défi à l'âne j'ai bien
compris pascal filles aiment les filles
c'est une chanson qui avait créé des
médailles à 30 ans que françois ozon a
repris dans son film et kahlan a entendu
en ce sens ce film il m'a proposé de la
chanter chansons donc fait pas dalida
qui n'avait pas exactement son âge à ce
moment là et j'ai été étonné le voir
qu'il avait choisi cette chanson il la
chantait je trouvais que j'avais
beaucoup de l'intensité les
téléspectateurs l'ont pensé aussi je
continue à le penser
voilà je me pose une question je te
réponds voilà d'accord t'as pas la voix
de mon physique méthane belle voix mais
t'as pas la voix de son physique
quoi
ouais pour ne pas vivre seul des filles
aiment des filles dont l'aller notre
faute
voilà c'est ça qu'il entendait c'est
vachement bien ses cheveux ses passes et
une à quel âge lan ses 17 attend c'est
des trucs
voilà alors ce morceau ce morceau ce
morceau est extrait de la compil
officiel entrée d'artistes vous
connaissez orlando halal
je les connais un petit peu puisque je
connais un petit peu le parcours des
haines ségara way et donc vous savez qu
orlando exige le clip vous savez ça vous
tenez comme mitterrand il ya des
références plus déplaisante que celle là
non je demandais pas ses prix pourquoi
bah oui c'est juste pour montrer que je
me le donnes j'allais à la rose et le
solutré avec nous c'était pour dire cher
bruno gaccio tout le monde le sait bien
sûr mais pourquoi c'est sa fidélité à
différents prix nord voilà si sa
fidélité à mi temps n'ont pas d'amis on
se pousse déficit donc vous allez
regarder votre caméra lan et vous allez
dire magnéto serge magnéto serge